there's a really good indicator or clue
for predicting heart attacks okay and
it's just looking at your earlobe yeah a
little crease in the bottom of your
earlobe starting from where the hole is
coming out 45 degrees as you see in this
image right here
go to the mirror right now take a look
to see if you have this pause the video
come back I'm going to tell you exactly
what this is all about and what to do if
you have it all right you're back okay
what is going on with this earlobe and
and what do you mean the crease on the
ear what happens when you have coronary
artery disease or another name for that
is cardiovascular disease is you lose
blood flow usually through an artery to
the heart muscle and this affects your
entire body circulation you start losing
collateral circulation what is
collateral circulation
well if your heart becomes obstructive
in some way you get collateral or extra
uh circulation or extra arteries that
start to Branch out and serve as a plan
B blood supply through the heart muscle
those are collateral arteries so what
happens when you get this chronic lack
of blood flow to your heart okay you
start losing circulation in the
peripheral part of your body first in
the earlobe is part of the periphery and
without this blood supply to the tiny
capillaries in your earlobes you start
losing elastin connective tissue
cartilage and it starts to wrinkle up
and this little crease shows up in about
71 percent of everyone with coronary
artery disease but it's also found in
other conditions like diabetes high
blood pressure it's found in smokers but
it's most commonly found with people
with heart problems now since heart
attacks are the number one cause of
death you should know this indicator not
just for yourself but for other people
too because if you see this you can let
the person know they need to go get it
checked out and they need to do
something ASAP now why the urgency well
the first symptom of a heart attack over
50 percent of the time is death so there
is no symptoms or warning signs you just
dropped dead so you want to pay
attention and you want to use this clue
as a prediction of what could happen and
also you should realize that this is not
just happening in your earlobe it's
happening throughout the entire body the
arteries can become thicker you can have
a lot of oxidative stress and a loss of
a lot of the collateral circulation in
your body so very simply there's four
things you need to do okay immediately
number one
you need to go on the healthy version of
the ketogenic diet with intermittent
fasting okay there's just no options you
need to start that it's going to help
you tremendously number two you want to
start a regular routine exercise program
okay that's going to flood the body with
a lot more oxygen including the heart
and you want to be consistent and you
pretty much want to keep this in for the
rest of your life the next thing I would
recommend is something that's very very
important for the inside of your
arteries and the heart muscle and it's a
type of vitamin E called tocatrinals
tocatrinals is like 50 times stronger
than tocopherols okay so when you buy
tugotrinols
you don't want to get tocatrinos mixed
with tocopherols you want to get just a
pure tocotrino mix or tocotrino complex
okay that is going to drive oxygen to
the heart muscle itself
and it's also going to protect the
inside of the vascular system it's one
of the most potent antioxidants that you
can get and especially good for the
heart it's also good for the liver as
well it can actually slow down the
progression of a fatty liver all right
the next thing is to start to increase
the omega-3 fatty acids and the best
Omega-3 is the caliber oil
it's better than fish oils because not
only does cod liver oil have the omega-3
fatty acids but it also has vitamin A
and vitamin D which are also important
in many different things including heart
health
and the last thing I'm going to
recommend is to make sure you take
something called vitamin K2 that keeps
the calcium from building up in the
arteries and you want to take vitamin K2
with vitamin D3 so I just wanted to
create this quick video to give you
something really simple to use as a
predictor now if you have not seen my
recent video that I just released on the
worst food for the cardiovascular system
and by the way it's not sugar okay
there's something else if you haven't
seen that video I put it up right here
check it out